an important day
for a couple of reasons one for the nfl
one for the rest of the world the
election the trade deadline also that
day the trade deadline this year because
of covet peter you touched on it earlier
the urgency that the ravens had to get
yannick and gawkway you got to get these
guys in the door yesterday was really
the last day if you want to have a guy
have a full practice week before week
nine so i don't know how much we're
gonna see between now and tuesday what
do you think
i really thought mike we would see two
or three trades
not just the carlos dunlop trade uh on
wednesday i thought we would see two or
three trades yesterday we saw none but i
think what that means is that most teams
are looking at this that you know they
don't want to add salary
this year
because let's say you trade for a guy
let's say and i know one team was very
interested in ryan kerrigan uh the
washington pass rusher who i think could
be a great ad for some team but if you
take ryan carrigan here's what that
means you have to basically pay about
five and a half million dollars okay and
add that to your cap this year so and
it's basically taking away from money
that you could you could save in 2021
because if you have money left over this
year
you can add it on to your number of 175
for next year and so that's why to me i
thought you would see more but guys like
ryan carrigan you know guys like
you know a lot of veteran players quite
honestly who have big numbers this year
that's why teams are shying away from
them
and four teams that don't play week nine
so maybe they're still in play to do a
deal browns bengals rams eagles you
don't have that same urgency because
you're thinking week number 10 anyway so
maybe one of those teams will do
something maybe there's a receiver that
that has that ability to stretch the
field that catches the eye of kevin
stefanski and the browns and they try to
do something in that regard but yeah i i
think that you know in most years we
build up this anticipation that
something's going to happen and usually
nothing really does i just think but
there were 12 trades last year mike and
there's 12 trades last year
and it was set up to be a rich trade
season this year and again maybe it will
be but there's only been five to this
point and so we'll see what happens in
the next four days
there's always those names that bubble
up
that that end up fizzling out and it
ends up being guys we weren't thinking
about who end up being traded regardless
of the total number
that that you know you get the
anticipation oh could this guy be traded
there's all the rumors maybe he's going
to be traded maybe he's going to be
traded and it seems like they can never
really quite work it out and i agree
with you the idea of balancing how much
you want to invest in your roster this
year versus how much of that cap space
you want to be able to carry over to
next year so you can do business that's
going to be a factor as well and also
peter look with seven spots per
conference
it's too early for most of these teams
to say
we're selling off assets i mean a lot of
these teams are still alive that
otherwise would be dead in any other
year i mean even you know except for the
jets who's really as a practical matter
done we saw how quickly the falcons
could turn around their vibe with a win
last night if the vikings would beat the
packers on sunday at green bay all of a
sudden they're feeling different and
maybe maybe
it's this one more week of games that
will cause some of these teams to start
making phone calls even if it doesn't
mean another team getting the benefit of
that player come sunday of next week
assuming the eagles win this game
against dallas on sunday night i would
expect howie roseman you're right mike
with a bye the following week
to
make 48 phone calls in the next 20 next
48 hours
uh because howie roseman is a guy who
doesn't uh shy away from making any
deals and i'm not saying he's the type
of guy who says i'll worry about the
2021 cap next year but i think if he
sees that his team is capable of turning
it around and he thinks maybe that kevin
zeitler or he can go get a good
offensive lineman somewhere and rent
them for the last nine weeks of the
season eight weeks i wouldn't put it
past him at all
hey and this team has a history of
getting hot late in the year 2017 when
carson wentz was gone and everybody
thought they were done they win the
super bowl 2018 he gets hurt again
everybody thinks they're done they get
within a whisker of the final four last
year five and seven they put the foot on
the gas they win the division and if
carson wentz doesn't suffer that
concussion maybe they win then so the
eagles are one of the few teams where
you could say
there's value peter in going all in
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports